N: C'est vraiment chelou ces cheveux là
faudrait vraiment que je pense à...
à me racheter une tête.
F: Tu fais une pierrecrocite
Salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec... Nicolas Meyrieux
N: Ah mer**. C'est là qu'il faut regarder
F: Ouais
N: Parce que je me fais avoir à chaque fois en regardant là
F: J'ai envie de vous dire, La Barbe
N: The Barber
N: The Bebar, Mec
Nicolas Meyrieux alias La Barbe alias tu cliques ici, si tu connais pas et après tu reviens voir la vidéo.
N: C'est vachement bien fait.
F: Et au moment où j'ai fait le geste, ça a fait *pfiou*
F: Souvent quand je vous explique certains concepts des astuces ou des choses comme ça, dans les commentaires,
vous trouvez ça trop compliqué ou pas faisable et vous auriez aimé une démonstration
je vais faire mieux qu'une démonstration
Je vais apprendre quelque chose à Nicolas
N: Oui
F: Et Nicolas tu vas essayer de le faire sur moi après
N: Je vais quelque part devenir mentaliste moi aussi
F: Mais c'est ça
N: Tu sais que c'est un de mes rêves
F: Clairement ça. C'est vrai?
N: Parce que les gens ne savent pas forcément mais nous, on se connait de la scène à la base.
F: Oui c'est vrai. On se connait depuis plus longtemps que ça.
N: Et... et c'est... ça m'arrivait de te présenter sur scène, tes numéros
F: Exact
N: Et quand tu passais, à chaque fois j'étais bluffé et j'essayais à chaque fois de lui faire, je n'ai jamais réussi
*Rire de Fabien*
F: Je vais t'apprendre quelque chose sur le non verbal
je lui ai laissé le choix entre des maths, de la mémoire,  du non verbal
il a choisi du non verbal
donc on va faire référence à la vidéo que vous allez trouver dans la description de cette vidéo là
L'idée c'est que dans quelques minutes, tu vas être capable de trouver à quel film je pense.
N: C'est un peu mon rêve ça, c'est un peu mon RÊVE
F: Et si il y avait 3 personnes tu pourrais trouver à quel film pense les 3 personnes. C'est ENORME
F: Dans un 1er temps, je vais...
N: Ceci est un message à ma famille
je vais vous faire le tour pendant toutes les vacances de Noël
*Rire de Fabien*
F: C'est obligé
N: Ça, c'est obligatoire
F: Dans un 1er temps on va faire une liste de film
c'est pas un film que je vais prendre au hasard, c'est un film qu'on va prendre parmi une liste
N: Ah on la fait tout les 2
F: Ouais ouais ça ira plus vite.
*Confection de la liste en accéléré*
F: Si tu ne connaissais pas les films, ça ne t'empêcherait pas de faire le tour
N: Non?
F: Parce qu'en fait, il y a juste la personne, elle va devoir visualiser, un film...
je suis toujours dans le champs? oui
un film qu'elle connait elle.
donc toi tu n'es pas assujetti à ça
parce que toi tu vas juste...
N: Assujetti
F: à la TVA
*rire de Nicolas*
F: Alors, concernant le plan de compta
N: C'est bien parce qu'il y a un petit clin d’œil par rapport à notre conversation d'avant
F: Tout à fait. que j'ai filmé et mis en ligne également
N: Ah oui d'accord
ah ben c'est bien parce que je fais parti des...
F: Moi je fais parti du système donc euh...
F: Tu vas me demander de penser à un de ces films
dans quelques secondes tu vas jouer ton rôle de mentaliste
et de fermer les yeux
je vais devoir te faire confiance et fermer les yeux.
une fois que la personne à les yeux fermés, donc quand j'aurai les yeux fermés
je dois rester le plus neutre possible
et toi, tu vas lire les films un par un
N: OK
F: Tu vas lire Inception, *fait une pause*
N: OK c'est génial, parce que c'est exactement le tour que tu faisais avec les numéros
F: Oui c'est vrai
N: Que j'essayais de savoir
N: C'est trop bien *claque des mains*
N: Je vais enfin comprendre
F:  Bronson, Matrix, etc...
tu vas laisser quelques secondes entre chaques
et mon job à moi
et c'est toi qui va me le dire à moi, m'en informer.
Les spectateurs ne le seront jamais en avance.
Mon job à moi ça va être de penser à ce film. Quand tu vas dire le nom de mon film
N: Il va y avoir une réaction
F: Il va surtout falloir que je le visualise à ce moment là
N: OK
F: Dès que tu dis son nom, il faut que je m'imagine que le film est en train de se dérouler,
je prends une séquence dans ma tête et je le visualise devant moi
Pourquoi les yeux fermés, parce que ça sera plus simple pour toi
Bizarrement les mouvements oculaires,
quand on a les yeux fermés se voient beaucoup plus que les yeux ouverts
Si je fais juste des petits mouvements léger comme ça, tu vas pas trop les voir
alors que *ferme les yeux*  regarde derrière les paupières
N: Oui tout à fait
F: On voit beaucoup mieux
F: D'ailleurs essaye de le faire toi même devant un miroir
N: Et il me prend pour un c** à ce moment là
F: Ouais et c'est pas faux. C'est... Tu vois le mentalisme commence à venir
tu commences à pressentir ce que je pense.
C'est incroyable. Je t'avais fait cette promesse.
Je te laisse faire. Là on part sur 12 films. Tranquilles.
N: Facile
F: Facile
N: Ça va être peut être un petit peu long pour les gens qui regardent mais...
F: Je vais peut être me mettre un peu comme ça et tu vas te mettre un peu comme ça.
Comme ça, vous aussi vous pouvez essayer de le faire en même temps
N: Ah oui, vous essayez de le mentaliser
F: Alors,  je ne suis pas si petit que ça, je me suis mis dans le champs de la caméra
*Rire de Nicolas*
F: OK vas y
N: Alors
attends parce qu'on voit pas très bien ta tête
F: C'était humide c'est foutu
N: C'était un peu dégueulasse quand même.
F: Je ne veux... je ne vais pas monter cette vidéo moi même
*Rire de Nicolas*
F: J'ai pas envie de voir cette image, c'est pour ça.
Si quelqu'un veut monter cette vidéo ?!
N: Bon aller
on y va
Inception
Bronson
Matrix
Space Jam
Roger Rabbit
The mask
Doctor Who
Mister Robot
Starbuck
Demain
La belle verte
Star Wars
Putain c'est chaud mec !
F: Alors déjà est ce que tu penses l'avoir?
N: Non
J'ai... j'ai... j'ai
F: *Rire* Non, pas MMMaaaalll
N: Au moins je suis honnête, je ne vais pas faire genre
Il y a un truc ou il y a eu quand même plus de mouvement
il y en a un
F: On va voir si tu as bon ou pas après
euh... le petit défaut que tu pourrais avoir,
et c'est sûrement quelques choses que je vous ai mal expliqué dans la 1ère vidéo
tout l'importance... et là c'est cool de le faire
C'est de bien prendre le temps entre chaque films, parce que le temps moi d'enclencher le processus d'imaginaire
N: Bien sûr
F: Et de commencer à voir des choses devant moi et sûrement générer des mouvements
Tu es peut être passé à l'autre film
c'était très rapide, il faut prendre le temps
N: Là, je suis allé trop vite?
F: Là, tu es allé trop vite là.
N: Je suis allé trop vite
F: En tout cas, si toi tu considères que tu n'as pas eu assez d'informations, c'est que tu es allé trop vite.
N: OK
F: Tu vois.
Prends toujours un peu plus le temps. D'après toi je pensais à quel film?
N: Tu viens de l'écrire là?
F: Ouais
N: OK donc c'est pas le film auquel je pensais,
parce que tu as beaucoup trop écrit par rapport au titre du film que je pensais
F: Sauf, si je veux essayer de te bluffer et que...
N: Bon je te le dis, je te le dis
N: The Mask
F: Ouais tu vois.
N: *Cri de joie* ALLEZZZZZ
*Rire de Nicolas*
F: En fait, quand... quand... ça s'est un réflexe que j'ai en spectacles
quand j'écris quelque chose sur un carnet
N: Ah tu as fais exprès
F: Je fais toujours pleins de traits pour que la personne ne puisse pas....
N: Oh tu es un petit bat***
N: Mais tu as vu moi, je suis malin parce que j'ai commencé à me dire "Non c'est pas possible"
F: Mais comme ça, ça créé un suspens
Bien joué.
N: Yes
F: Parce que tu pensais pas, forcément, l'avoir
N: Non je pensais pas forcément.
F: Mais donc tu l'as
N: OK cool
F: Est ce que ça te dit qu'on le refasse ou j'en choisi plusieurs?
N: Ouuuhh
F: Et je ne te dis pas combien j'en choisi
*Bam Bam*
N: [Réfléchi] Attends parce que là déjà je suis content d'avoir trouver
donc moi j'aime bien palier par palier
tu sais, moi je suis un mec, j'aime bien connaitre les choses dans l'ensemble
F: OK
N: Je suis le genre de conn**d quand je fais un jeu vidéo
je n'arrête pas d'y jouer tant que je n'ai pas fini à 100%
F: Toutes les étoiles et tout
N: Oui exactement c'est comme ça
N: j'ai vraiment besoin de palier par palier, je veux toujours, tout connaitre sur tout.
F: Le problème c'est que je me suis mis, donc après, à New Super Mario Bros 2 sur la 3 DS
N: Ouais
F: Donc je fais tout les mondes, tout les secrets, tout les passages, toutes les étoiles
et puis il y avait un petit challenge en plus avoir 1 million de pièces
tu vois
N: Tu as dû le faire
F: Donc je les fait
*Rire de Nicolas*
F: Et... tu sais ce que tu as quand tu atteints  les 1 millions de pièces?
N: Non
F: Un nouvel écran de démarrage
N: Olé
F: Bande de Bat**d
N: On était heureux.
F: Put***.
N: Alors du coup, qu'est ce qu'on fait?
F: Euh... attends je choisi, je choisi, je choisi, je choisi, j'en choisi 2
N: Seulement
F: Oui c'est déjà pas mal
N: Ah ouais
F: Ou 3
N: Put*** tout à l'heure tu me dis que...
N: Non non mais là *Rire des 2*
N: Choisi. tu en prends combien?
F: J'en prends 3.
N: Tu en prends 3
F: J'en prends 3 ma gueule
N: OK. Allez
F: Je ferme les yeux ou pas? ou tu veux faire les yeux ouverts?
*Rire de Fabien*
N: Non mais attends tu veux toujours me mettre des trucs en plus
Non mais les yeux ouverts je sais que tu vas...
F: Non mais tout ça pour dire que "Regardez
vous avez pleins de paliers possible après au fur et à mesure pour affiner
Là en vrai on va faire 3 les yeux fermés
N: 3 les yeux fermés et après peut être qu'on en fera 1 les yeux ouverts
N: Au moment, où tu entends le film
que tu as choisi
il faut vraiment que tu y penses, que tu visualises dans ta tête, il faut vraiment que tu vois une séquence
c'est très important
pour m'aider à le trouver
F: Comme si il était devant moi quoi !
N: Comme si il était... comme si tu étais au cinéma
en train de manger des petits pop corn
de boire du coca et de faire chier les gens autour de toi
F: La précision de ce mec, c'est incroyable, incroyable.
Je suis prêt
N: Tu y es, tu vas au cinéma. Tu es dans quel cinéma?
F: Je suis... au... MK2 dans le 20ème.
N: Très bien
petit partenariat avec le cinéma MK2
*Rire de Fabien et Nicolas*
Allez tu te concentres
Non mais là tu rigoles, tu ne te concentres pas
F: Je souris, parce que tu me rends heureux
N: Tu as choisis 3 films?
F: Oui
N: On y va
Inception
Bronson
Matrix
Space jam
Roger Rabbit
The Mask
Doctor Who
Mister Robot
Starbuck
Demain
La belle verte
Star Wars
OK
F: C'est bon?
N: Je pense
F: Je fais comme tout à l'heure je les note
il y avait un petit côté comme ça...
N: Attends, attends j'avais mis mon truc
F: Prends ta feuille
N: Ah mince j'avais mis mes doigts sur lesquel je pensais en fait
F: Ben remet les
N: Donc
le premier c'est Matrix
F: Ouais
N: OK
et après je pense à Starbuck
F: Ouais, bon tant pis
N: Et Star Wars
F: D'accord
N: argh j'ai 1 sur 3?
F: Ouais.
T'as... t'as un sans faute
N: Noooon
F: Matrix, Starbuck et Star Wars
N: Oulala
F: Pouah c'est qui le mentaliste
N: Ouah je suis trop content.
Bon j'arrête l'humour, place à la magie maintenant
Attention Nicolas vous émerveille
*Rire des 2*
F: Nicolas le Magicien.com
et en plus, vraiment, j'ai pas cherché à t'aider
puisque j'ai sûrement eu des moments, ailleurs
qui sont des sauts normaux en fait sur...
quand tu as les yeux fermés, qui n'indique rien
Et j'ai pas cherché à faire du... [Exagère les mouvements]
tu vois genre, à surjouer le truc
j'ai eu le même légèreté qu'un spectateur.
N: C'est génial mon gars
F: C'est drôle?
N: J'ai eu du premier coups les 2 en plus
F: Ouais
N: oh je suis trop content. Merci
F: Bravo Mec !
N: Je suis trop content
F: Est ce que tu t'es bluffé?
N: Ah complètement
F: Cool
N: Ah là je suis choqué.
F: Mais ça, c'est mortel. C'est... je crois que j'en referai de temps en temps
des trucs comme ça avec d'autres guests
parce que vous, vous vous auto-bluffez
et je suis sûr que...
N: Et je pense que même les gens, ils vont pas y croire, ils vont se dire "ouais c'est ça"
F: Oh si je pense...
N: Non mais tu imagines du premier coup les 2
alors que j'avais jamais fait
F: C'est pour ça que je les ai écrit avant pour...
pour pas qu'il y ai d'ambiguïté tu vois
N: Ah ouais
F: parce que si tu me les dis et que je te dis "Oui c'est ça"
pfff il y a pas de preuve
N: Ouais
F: Là je t'ai prouvé que tu avais bon.
N: Ouais, ouais
F: Allez voir la vidéo, où je fais les explications. C'est plus propre, c'est plus long, c'est plus posé
il y a pleins de petites astuces en plus
Mais vous voyez que c'est complètement possible
N: Ah oui. là c'est vraiment... je suis choqué
F: Mais,...
N: Là, dans ma tête je suis un put*** de magicien, en vrai
je suis trop content
F: Non mais de ouf
N: Donc vraiment faite le c'est facile.
c'est facile, en tout cas moi ça m'a paru facile
F: J'espère que ça sera inspirant ce qu'il vous aura fait Nicolas
et Nicolas est lui même inspirant sur la manière de penser et de faire des vidéos
grâce à la Barbe
à la chaîne de Nicolas Meyrieux
et tes vlogs aussi sont super bien
N: Je te remercie
F: Donc allez voir la chaîne de Nicolas Meyrieux. Prenez ces quelques secondes
je vous mets le lien dans la description et peut être une petite fiche par là
ah bé non je vous mets dans la description
et également le petit cercle
qui va apparaître entre nous 2
N: Put*** comme je le fais bien, tu vois
F: Wouah
allez voir ça c'est mortel
comme d'habitude si la vidéo vous a plu, vous pouvez liker et vous abonner
Rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !